le problème de la vaccination se pose
également Tunisie le pas sanitaire
bientôt obligatoire pour contraindre les
plus riches en
fait le point à Tunis avec notre
correspondant Bassem Shelby
tunisien et étranger de plus de 18 ans
de Vendée le 22 décembre prochain
présenter un pas sanitaire pour circuler
dans certains lieux publics et
infrastructures touristiques alors que
le pays a connu des débuts difficiles
dans sa campagne vaccinal elle grâce à
l'aide international 5 million de
Tunisiens ont pu mettre à jour leur
carnet de santé un taux de vaccination
de 44,5 pourcents sur le ministère de la
Santé insuffisant selon le gouvernement
tunisien pour inciter les plus
récalcitrants à se faire une autre s'il
est le sérum anti covit les autorités
ont décidé d'instaurer le passe à
sanitaire un document obligatoire pour
se rendre au cinéma au stade au
restaurant ou encore au musée mais
également à l'université au tout
établissement public et compris elle les
hôpitaux pour ceux qui accompagne des
malades écouter tous les espaces se
relevant du secteur public sont appelés
à charger les agent d'accueil de veiller
à l' application du décret présidentiel
numéro 1 de l'année 2021 en date du 22
octobre 2021 relatif aux pas sanitaire
qui interdit l'accès à ces lieux en cas
de non présentation du passé qui sera
obligatoire à partir du 22 décembre au
courant la président du gouvernement et
le ministère de la Santé non pas
l'intention de revenir sur l'application
de te créer leur est de même pour les
voyageurs qui rappelons-le depuis le 1er
décembre dernier on l'obligation de
présenter un test PCR de moins de 48
heures assorti d'une preuve de
vaccination pour certains médias
tunisien et Défenseur des droits humains
cette restriction ne passe pas il
dénonce une violation des droits
notamment celui de circuler qui juge
anticonstitutionnel écouter il n'y aura
pas eu de débat autour du Pass sanitaire
en Tunisie le Palais de Carthage a
décidé est le peuple devra se soumettre
une aubaine pour le régime du président
qu'à Sayed qui multiplie les
restrictions de circulation souvent
arbitraire cette nouveauté s'inscrit
dans un contexte déjà marqué par la
multiplication des limitations de
circulation depuis le début de l'ère
Kais à l'aide des restrictions décider
sur fond de règlement de compte
politique de nombreux pays d'Afrique ont
récemment rendu obligatoire le pas
sanitaire pour se rendre à différents
public Togo Rwanda Maroc et maintenant
en Tunisie l'Afrique a deux petit à
petit impasse Annie terre souvent décrit
en Europe